Traduttore: Cecilia Secco
Revisore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
Allora, la prima cosa da dire
è che mi sono portato
la claque, chiaramente.
Sono qui, mi hanno detto,
per farvi un dono,
per raccontarvi una storia,
e questa storia inizia il giorno
in cui ho contattato
una delle organizzatrici del TEDx,
ovvero Cecilia.
Ero a casa
e stavo guardando
un TEDx delle edizioni passate,
incuriosito dalla singolarità
degli argomenti,
quando all'improvviso ho avuto
come una sorta di illuminazione, un'idea.
Avevo un'idea.
Così ho preso il computer,
ho scritto subito una mail
che ho inviato così di getto,
dicendo che avevo un'idea
che sapevo sarebbe stata perfetta
per il pubblico di TED.
Non sono solito agire di impulso,
ma questa volta è accaduto.
Non mi aspettavo la risposta di Cecilia,
che è arrivata in giornata
e che diceva, "Va bene, chiamami subito".
Bene, adesso la chiamo subito, fantastico.
Quest'apertura improvvisa mi è piaciuta:
“Adesso la chiamo e le dico la mia idea”.
Ma quale idea?
Così, da buono psicologo di me stesso,
mi sono fermato e mi sono ascoltato.
Ho provato a sentire quale era l'idea
dentro di me che voleva venire fuori,
qual era il contenuto che voleva
emergere da questa interazione.
Potrei parlare del rapporto
che ho con mio fratello,
ma sarebbe una cosa
troppo personale
e poi lui, di sicuro,
non sarebbe d'accordo - no.
Potrei parlare di cosa vuol dire crescere
in un piccolo paesino del sud,
che si chiama Quindici,
di 1.500 abitanti...
A Rovigo? No.
Potrei parlare di come
si raggiunge il successo -
se solo sapessi come si fa.
Niente.
L'idea si era nascosta dentro di me
e si era rifugiata da qualche parte,
forse spaventata dalla troppa
apertura dell'organizzatrice.
E se volesse fregarmi?
No, basta. Basta paranoie.
Adesso la chiami e le dici
la prima cosa che ti viene in mente;
se andrà bene, bene;
altrimenti, vuol dire
che avrai fatto una figuraccia.
Così prendo il telefono,
compongo il numero, la chiamo
e - “Driiin”, suona il citofono.
Poso il telefono, corro al citofono.
"È l’idea", penso.
E invece era la mia compagna.
Sale su e le dico
quello che stavo facendo,
che avevo fatto questa azione di impulso,
non sapevo nemmeno io perché.
E lei mi dice che la mia
era una fantastica idea,
che avevo avuto un'ottima pensata,
che sicuramente avevo
tante cose da condividere
con le persone di interesse.
Io le dico che sono stato uno stupido,
non avrei mai dovuto farlo,
avrei dovuto pensarci prima,
“Come mi è potuta venire
in mente una cosa del genere?”
E poi, all'improvviso,
mi viene fuori una frase
che un bambino mi ripeteva
un po’ di tempo fa,
e che fa così:
“No chiamare”, con la erre moscia.
Eccola. È l'idea, è nata.
Ha 12 anni in realtà,
si chiama Lucas e porta
dei lunghi capelli biondi.
Lucas è un bambino, ma non è
un bambino come tutti gli altri:
oltre a essere un bambino,
Lucas è un poeta,
Lucas è un anticonformista,
Lucas è un rivoluzionario,
Lucas è un filosofo
e anche un pensatore.
A differenza di tutti
gli altri bambini -
o meglio, in comune
con tutti gli altri bambini,
a Lucas non piace andare a scuola.
Ma a differenza
di tutti gli altri bambini,
Lucas non ama tanto giocare.
Lucas ama più viaggiare
e vedere posti nuovi nel mondo,
Lucas ama i grattacieli di New York,
Lucas ama le cascate del Niagara,
Lucas ama vedere
città nuove che sorgono,
come ad esempio Dubai.
Ma più di ogni altra cosa,
su tutte le altre cose,
a Lucas piacciono i gonfiabili.
Lucas farebbe qualsiasi cosa
pur di andare sui gonfiabili.
Pensate che a sette anni
è scappato di casa
ed è andato sui gonfiabili
nel parco vicino casa.
Per fortuna che la polizia l'ha ritrovato,
altrimenti probabilmente
sarebbe ancora lì a saltellare.
Lucas ama la musica classica,
ma non quella che
possiamo ascoltare tutti:
Debussy non gli piace,
chissà Giovanni Allevi,
non gliel'ho mai fatto ascoltare.
A lui piace lo “Stabat
Mater” di Pergolesi,
“Il lago dei cigni” di Tchaikovsky.
Lucas non ama vedere le cose
in disordine a casa sua:
in particolare,
Lucas non ama vedere
le fronde dei tappeti
che si confondono l’una con le altre:
devono stare belle allineate,
una a fianco all'altra,
e guai a chi osa toccarle.
Ah, dimenticavo, due piccoli particolari:
Lucas ha un disturbo
dello spettro autistico
e un deficit intellettivo,
meglio conosciuto come ritardo mentale,
quello che una volta
chiamavamo ritardo mentale.
Un'altra cosa che ho
dimenticato di dire su Lucas
è che quando le cose rotte, a casa sua -
quando le cose si rompono,
a casa sua si portano giù in cantina.
Così, quando si è rotto lo stereo
con cui ascoltavamo la musica,
Lucas ha voluto portarle
“a…giù…stare”.
Lucas è davvero un poeta.
E come queste tante altre
che adesso non sto qui a raccontarvi.
Sarebbe difficile davvero spiegarvi
che cos'è un disturbo
dello spettro autistico
in 11 minuti e 27 secondi
in questo momento,
anche perché di solito
si dice sull'autismo
che “ogni bambino con autismo
è diverso da un altro”,
ma d'altronde ogni bambino
anche è diverso da un altro
e quindi sarebbe
una difficoltà al quadrato,
quella di spiegarvi cos'è l’autismo.
Spero con questo talk di incuriosirvi
e spero che una volta tornati a casa
possiate dedicare cinque minuti
alla ricerca su Google
di che cos'è l'autismo.
Ma torniamo a noi.
Quando ho conosciuto Lucas,
Lucas stava malissimo.
Passava le giornate a dare
calci al muro, calci a letto,
urlava, stava male.
E anche noi stavamo male,
perché non capivamo cosa avesse.
Poi, complice un intervento farmacologico,
psicologico e anche comportamentale,
Lucas ha iniziato a stare sempre meglio,
sempre meglio, sempre meglio.
I comportamenti
problema[tici] sono diminuiti
e abbiamo potuto iniziare
a instaurare una relazione, a conoscerci.
Lucas non è di molte parole,
però potevamo giocare insieme.
Così un giorno sono andato a casa sua
con in testa le mie belle idee
su quello che avrei fatto con lui.
In gergo tecnico si chiamano
“programmi di apprendimento”.
E avevo in testa che cosa fare con lui,
ma quel giorno Lucas ha iniziato a parlare
come non aveva mai fatto
prima di quel momento.
Io: “Vuoi vedere cosa c’è qui, eh?
Guarda che cosa ho qui”
Guarda, c’è un calzino!
Lucas: “Nonno, nonno è morto”
Io: “Vieni a vedere che cos'ho”
Lucas: “Quando Lucas era piccolo…
prima ieri... prima due ieri…
prima altri due di ieri,
ma poi c’era nonno”
Io: “Prima c’era nonno…”
Lucas: “E ora non più”
Io: “E ora non c'è più”
Lucas: “Altra… prima Otto.
(un gioco con cui giocavamo)
Prima, altro Otto”
Io: “Prima c’era nonno…”
Lucas: “Poi non c'è”
Io: “E ora non c'è più”
Lucas: “Prima non c’è più…
poi c'era nonno”
Io: “Prima c’era… e ora non c’è più”
Lucas: “C’era nonno…”
Io: “Prima… ora non c’è”
Lucas: “C’era nonno… c’era nonno”
Io: “E com'era Lucas
quando c’era nonno?”
Lucas: “Piccolo…”
Io: “Era piccolo ed era felice”
Lucas: “Prima tre… morto… poi c’era nonno”
Io: “Prima c’era il nonno,
con Lucas, nonno e Lucas...”
“Prima contrare [“incontrare”,
pronunciato male]”
Io: “Prima??”
Lucas: “contrare”
Io: “contrare?”
Lucas: “Poi c’era nonno”
Io: “Non ho capito”
Lucas: “ncontrare,
incontrare, poi c’era nonno…
c’era nonno”
Io: “C'era nonno prima”
Lucas: “Si”
Io: “E ora nonno?”
Lucas: “Non c'è più”
Io: “E come sta Lucas?
È felice o triste ora?
Ora che il nonno non c’è Lucas è...?”
Lucas: “Triste”
Io: “Triste. Invece
quando c’era nonno?”
Lucas: “Prima… altra… no c’era nonno…
non c’era nonno… altra c’era nonno”
Io: “Prima c’era nonno… ed era diverso…
ora nonno non c'è più”
Lucas: “Prima ncontrare…
c’era nonno… dopo c’era nonno,
dopo c'era nonno"
Io: “Allora”
Lucas: “Dopo [pronunciato
correttamente] c’era nonno…
ncontrare”
Io: “Vorresti che fosse qui?”
Lucas: “ncontrare… ncontrare non c’è più”
Io: “Ora non c’è più”
Lucas: “No ncontrare …
prima altra…
prima due…
prima altra”
Io: “Prima eravate in due… e ora?”
Lucas: “Prima c'ero…”
[20 secondi dopo]
Lucas: “C’era nonno.
c'era... Francesco c’era nonno”
Io: “Prima c'era il nonno, sì”
Lucas: “Poi non c'è più”
Io: “E ora non c’è più”
A questo punto,
ho buttato via i programmi
e ho preso un foglio di carta.
L’ho diviso a metà
e ho scritto da una parte “prima”
e dall'altra “dopo”.
Da una parte ho disegnato Lucas
con suo padre, sua madre e il nonno;
e dall'altra parte ho disegnato Lucas
ma senza nonno,
però con i due genitori.
Ho pensato che se avesse visto
che non era solo,
probabilmente si sarebbe sentito
meno sconfortato.
Stavamo cercando di evitare di introdurre
dei concetti molto complessi
come il paradiso, il cielo.
Però qualcuno deve avergli detto
che il nonno si trova in cielo.
E così, da quel giorno Lucas
è diventato un appassionato
di pianeti, stelle, astronauti e di Marte.
E anche dei piccioni,
con cui ogni tanto parla:
giocandoci, li imita.
Qualche volta Lucas, inoltre,
si ferma davanti a una finestra,
davanti alla finestra di casa sua,
e inizia a guardare il cielo.
E con il dito dipinge
delle traiettorie sopra le nuvole,
chissà, forse nella speranza
di reincontrare suo nonno.
“Bella storia”, mi ha detto Cecilia,
“ma ti manca l'idea”.
L’idea, mia cara Cecilia,
e a tutti voi,
è che senza gli altri siamo persi.
Che se quel giorno non fosse arrivata
la mia compagna,
probabilmente mi sarei perso
nelle mie idee
e probabilmente non sarei qui
a parlare con voi.
Che se Lucas non avesse superato
un suo limite strutturale
per potermi parlare,
probabilmente si sentirebbe ancora
molto solo e ancora molto sconfortato.
Che se io quel giorno
non lo avessi ascoltato,
probabilmente starei ancora pensando
che programmi di
apprendimento fare con Lucas,
invece di dedicare del tempo
per poter ascoltare,
per poter condividere
quello che lui aveva da dirmi.
L'idea è che le migliori idee
che possiamo avere
le abbiamo quando siamo
in contatto con gli altri,
con le persone che amiamo
e con le persone che ci amano.
Grazie.
(Applausi)